So basically,
to make a plan on.
How about you wanna click the plus button at the bottom
and then click plan?
And then, um,
you just put whatever plan name you want in.
I'll just put drinks.
And then you click the gift bit at the top,
and you can pick whatever gift you want.
Uh, select anyone from that list to add to the event.
And then you can change the date on here.
The little red dots you can see when people are busy,
when people aren't,
um, change the time.
See the bit at the top?
You can change it all day or not,
return it to the current or not.
Um, and then just click select
and you can put the details in.
Um, you can just type whatever you want here.
I'll just type drinks and.
And you can also put the location in at this bit too.
Uh, so if we're going to drink,
we could go to weather spoons,
for example, um,
and just pop that in there.
And once you've done all that,
just click create plan
and the plan is made.